nerves on show from Parliament's newest
MP as she waited for her leaders arrival
elected by a narrow margin and already
facing uncomfortable questions we need
to find a deal that protects workers
protects the living standards of the
people that live here also our
environment and our consumer so no
second referendum for you I have no idea
what's going to happen in Parliament but
when the Labour leader arrived the focus
was on one thing in breaking the victory
a victory won by fewer than 700 votes a
victory that saw the party lose a third
of the support it received in 2017 a
victory nonetheless since the punishing
European election results mr corbyn has
come under significant pressure to fully
embrace the second referendum but the
Peterborough result seems to have paid
to that I think it would be much better
if there was actually a general election
because we have a government with no
majority if you get the general election
you're looking for is your brexit policy
that you will renegotiate a deal along
the lines that you have set out and then
campaign for brexit that is going to be
Labour's general election policy I'm not
going to predict what's going to be
Labour's general election but you're the
leader these labor activists campaigned
hard on the doorsteps to mobilize voters
and they back mr corbyn's approach his
stance on brexit is the correct one it's
not as polarized as it as people like to
say you can't just be full remain or
full leave there has to be some balance
if you're going to address the concerns
of the nation but they're under no
illusions about how close things were
it's been a really difficult kind of
situation in a really difficult kind of
election to fight the brexit party had
been favourites to win in Peterborough
and impromptu photo call this afternoon
in Downing Street perhaps an attempt to
shift focus from that fact but Nigel
Farage is insistent there is more to
come
the only thing we failed to do
was to persuade enough conservative
voters that by voting conservative they
got labour by voting conservative they
got an on brexit ear to be elected and
that's it that's going to take it with
some time to understand that there are
parts of the country where the brexit
party is the only challenge of the labor
and it's that prospect which makes the
result in Peterborough so important
perhaps the most significant impacts of
the by-election here will be on the
conservative leadership contest the
contenders have wasted no time in
pointing to the pitiful performance of
the party here and using it to justify
their own proposed for exit strategies
how can you win back places like
Peterborough Mr Gove there is one point
on which the vast majority of Tory
candidates agree I think the result
reminds us of two things the vital
importance of delivering brexit and also
the vital importance of making sure that
we have a strong Conservative government
that can prevent Jeremy Corbyn in
getting into Downing Street and ruining
this country can you be Forrest Olson
where they differ is the question of
whether leaving without a deal is the
only way to avoid that scenario or the
thing most likely to bring it about it
was a narrow win for labour but one that
puts the Conservatives brexit conundrum
into stark relief and Jeremy Corbyn will
take that Tom reign at Sky News
Peterborough